في جلسه شهريه لمجلس الامن الدولي بشان
الاوضاع في سوريا قال جر بدرسن المبعوث
الم امميه الخاص الى سوريا ان هناك
ديناميات تصعيديه في سوريا وهو امر مقلق
وخطير وقال بيدرسن انه منذ عده اشهر هناك
ارتفاع في الضربات المتبادله بين قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه من جهه وتركيا وجماعات
المعارضه المسلحه من جهه اخرى وحذر بدر
مجلس الامن من السيناريو الذي تكون فيه
العمليات العسكريه واسعه النطاق التي تقوم
بها جهه فاعله واحده لها اثار غير مباشره
في جميع المسارح الاخرى بعد هدوء النسبي
لما يقربوا من ثلاث سنوات كما اشار الى ان
هذا تصعيدا لن يؤدي الى تفاقم الضرر
المدمر الذي لحق بالمدنيين السوريين فحسب
بل سيعرض ايضا الاستقرار الاقليميه للخطر
وست في الجماعات والارهابيه ذلك وفق
تصريحه
في الاثناء قالت مصادر الرسميه تركيه
للجزيره ان الجانب الروسي يبدوا الوجودا
لتلبيه مطالب تركيا في شمال سوريا كبديل
عن العمليه العسكريه واضافت المصادر وانا
انقر اشترطت سحاب قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
من منبج وعين العرب وتر رفعت كما اشترطت
عوده مؤسسات النظام السوري بما فيها
القوات الامنيه وحرس الحدود بديلا عما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
والسنادا للمصادر نفسها فقد اعطت انقره
مهله زمنيه لتلبيه شروطها والا سيكون
البديل عمليه عسكريه تشمل المناطق
المذكوره